herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt heute
zeige ich euch wie eine richtig einfache
Geburtstagstorte im Stil eines teddybärs
machen könnt und mit der Methode die wir
heute arbeiten könnt ihr wirklich jedes
Motiv zaubern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und vielleicht kommt später sogar noch
meine Schwester dazu die wohnt in Aachen
und wir treffen uns morgen auf dem
Geburtstag von meinem kleinen Neffen der
wird morgen ein Jahr alt
die Zeit vergeht einfach viel zu schnell
ja jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht dass
ich dieses Mal eine Torte mache die auf
jeden Fall jedem schmeckt die toll
aussieht die man aber auch in kurzer
Zeit herstellen kann denn ich muss sagen
wir haben heute nur etwa einen halben
Tag dafür Zeit das einzige was ich schon
vorbereitet habe sind die rührteigböden
das sind die mandelböden da findet ihr
bereits ein Grundrezept auf meinem Kanal
ich habe das ganze einfach auf 25 cm
Größe vorbereitet und das ganze auch
schon mal im Kühlschrank gelagert damit
die Böden sich einfach gut
durchschneiden lassen das heißt die
Böden sind jetzt schon ready und jetzt
geht's direkt los mit der Buttercreme
dafür nehme ich 660 g Milch 135 Gramm
Zucker etwas Salz und Tonka Paste 60 g
Stärke vier Eigelbe die habe ich schon
mal die weiche Butter das sind 420 g und
200 g Zartbitter Kuvertüre
das geht jetzt im Prinzip ganz einfach
ein bisschen Milch in den Topf geben
dann Zucker Salz und Tonka Pasta
dazugeben am besten direkt die Stärke
und die Eigelbe dazu und richtig schön
rühren die restliche Milch dazu gießen
und dann einfach schön rührend aufkochen
lassen
den Pudding dann am besten noch durch
einen Sieb streichen jetzt lacht mein
Sie bitte nicht aus ja ich habe das
größere sieht nicht gefunden ich weiß
nicht wo ist
halt ein bisschen schneller
meine Flotte Lotte ist weg mein
fleißiges Lieschen weg
man könnte meinen ich bin hier
ausgezogen
ich weiß nicht wo mein Zeug ist
und jetzt könnte ich hier noch die
Zartbitterkuvertüre dazugeben die
schmilzt einfach in der Restwärme und
den Pudding deckt ihr dann ab damit sich
an der Oberfläche keine Haut bildet und
lass den einfach auf Zimmertemperatur
abkühlen in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr
dann nämlich schon die Butter nehmen und
richtig schön weiß cremig verrühren so
ungefähr 10 Minuten lang
jetzt ist die butterweiß cremig und ihr
könnt den pudding esslöffelweise
einrühren am besten vorher kurz mit dem
Schneebesen durchrühren damit der
geschmeidig ist und hier gilt eigentlich
nur zu beachten dass der Pudding
wirklich auf Zimmertemperatur abgekühlt
ist wenn er zu warm ist schmilzt die
Butter ihr habt dann eine flüssige
Buttercreme man bekommt sie gerettet
aber es wäre jetzt einfach unnötig und
wenn sie zu kalt ist also sprich aus dem
Kühlschrank dann flockt die Butter also
wichtig beide Zutaten ins
Zimmertemperatur dann geht bei der
Buttercreme auch nichts schief falls die
Butter oder der Pudding doch zu kalt war
und die Buttercreme flockt müsst ihr das
ganze auf dem auf dem Wasserbad stellen
auf so einem warmes und noch mal
erwärmen aber beachtet einfach die
Raumtemperatur dann klappt alles
[Musik]
die Schokoladencreme gerade noch an der
Seite steht kann ich hier auch was
vorbereiten und zwar mache ich jetzt
noch so ein Crunch für die Torte dafür
nehme ich jetzt 100 g
Zartbitterschokolade da habe ich jetzt
wieder diese hier verwendet so wie
gerade eben beim Schokopudding auch 50 g
Mandeln das sind gestiftete Mandeln und
hier habe ich noch 100 Gramm Dinkel
Flakes bzw das sind ja irgendwie so
Dinkel
so die Kuvertüre jetzt einfach schmelzen
über einem warmen Wasserbad und dann
kommt das restliche Drittel dazu
und jetzt verrühre ich hier einfach die
Schokolade mit den dinkelpops ihr könnt
auch Cornflakes nehmen oder einfach
andere Zutaten die ihr gerne habt
dinkelflakes Cornflakes Haferflocken
Mandel Nüsse alles was ihr im
backschrank habt damit ihr einfach so
ein bisschen Crunch rein bekommt es wird
jetzt hier verrührt
[Musik]
die ist hier einfach auf eine Backfolie
und das lasse ich jetzt hier einfach
kurz fest werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte nur noch erwähnt haben dass
das eine extra Himbeerstrauch ist weil
wenn man vorne Beast Birds und
butterflies und hier ist extra dahinter
drauf der ist für alle Käfer Spinnen
Insekten und Krabbeltiere und das sind
extra
[Musik]
oh ich liebe dich so sehr
du bist so süß
[Gelächter]
jetzt kann die Torte befüllt werden ich
habe jetzt hier meinen mandelboden
bereits durchgeschnitten und jetzt nehmt
ihr euch einfach ein bisschen
Buttercreme dann kommen noch Himbeeren
rein die habe ich gerade draußen auf der
Terrasse gesammelt und noch dieser
Crunch einfach so dazwischen
dann wird das richtig richtig
[Musik]
dann kommt der nächste Boden drauf und
dann noch mal die Füllung tschüss
[Musik]
und fertig ist die Torte zumindest
fertig gefüllt
30 jetzt noch mal kurz glatt und dann
musst du jetzt aber erstmal in den
Kühlschrank und richtig gut durchkühlen
falls ihr die Zeit habt wirklich gerne
4-5 Stunden damit sie richtig fest wird
die Buttercreme und ich die Torte später
eben gut schneiden kann ansonsten könnte
es auch kurz ins Gefrierfach stellen
oder auch abdecken und übernachten den
Kühlschrank das ist auch gut weil sie
euch die Arbeit so ein bisschen
aufteilen wollt die restliche
Buttercreme die Decke ich jetzt nur ab
und lasse bei Raumtemperatur stehen wenn
es nicht so warm ist falls der Raum zu
warm ist dann ein bisschen in den
Kühlschrank man kann sie danach wieder
aufschlagen aber wie gesagt
normalerweise im besten Fall einfach per
Raumtemperatur
also
[Musik]
die Torte ist schön kalt und kann jetzt
mit der restlichen Creme bestrichen
werden ihr könnt jetzt direkt eigentlich
schon hier was wegschneiden denn die
Torte wird dann aufgestellt gar nicht zu
viel einfach nur dass er dann einen
schönen Halt hat
guckt mal richtig schön
und jetzt mit der Creme den Rest
bestreicht
[Musik]
wenn euch die Form weitestgehend gefällt
dann könnt ihr die Torte jetzt noch mal
kühlen die erste Schicht hier die ist
jetzt erstmal wichtig dass einfach alle
Krümel gebunden werden die Buttercreme
bleibt weiterhin hier bei Raumtemperatur
stehen und die Torte kommt wird eine
halbe Stunde in den Kühlschrank und in
der Zwischenzeit überlege ich mir schon
mal wie ich die Torte weiter dekoriere
und überlege mir wie groß hier das
Bärchen Gesicht wird und macht
vielleicht schon mal die Ohren dran ja
und dieses Stück hier
das ist zum Essen da
[Musik]
komm wir probieren gleich
probieren
[Musik]
nichts anderes mehr sagen
jetzt geht's an die Deko der Torte und
die mache ich jetzt nicht alleine
sondern habe tatkräftige Unterstützung
von niemandem geringeren als zweiter
Schwester
[Musik]
das ist meine Schwester wir sind gleich
alt weiter 29
ja wir backen jetzt für unsere Neffen
die Torte fertig ja
irgendwie helfen
ich dachte sie macht jetzt so ein
stumpfen
und wir müssen jetzt die Öhrchen Formen
und die Finger haben die Pfoten das
heißt Du darfst gerne das nehmen zum
Beispiel mit Pfoten kenne ich mich aus
ja während meiner Schwester hat einen
Hund im Moment zwei
Fondant mit CMC Pulver verknetet wir
sind braun bisschen helleres Braun und
Schwarz und die Basis ist immer so eine
Kugel die keine
Falten mehr hat
schwierig in meinem Alter
[Musik]
wie sie mich als Kind immer veräppelt
hat
wie ich dachte ich sei vom Müll
[Gelächter]
ich dachte Spaghetti werden aus Würmern
gemacht
ja stimmt habe ich alles gemacht ja ja
aber ich liebe sie wir hatten immer eine
schöne Kindheit
zwei Monate älter als Du bin durftet ihr
ja irgendwann auch immer mal bei mir
übernachten das war immer cool ne das
war immer schön
war nämlich schon recht früh aus dem
Haus hat auch geheiratet und dann dürft
mir immer da schlafen sind ins
Schwimmbad und ins Kino und essen
die Disco
sag das mein Papa sieht das
wir waren nicht in der Disco Papa also
ich schon aber sie nicht ich nee noch
nicht
[Musik]
also ich finde das sieht doch schon mal
süß aus
Lichtpunkte rein
kleben wir noch auf ein Mund und dann
kann man die Torte glatt streichen
super süß und vor allem ganz ganz
einfach zu machen für alle die zu einem
ersten Geburtstag oder zum 5.10 18 egal
wie eine Teddy Torte machen wollen okay
Eiche macht jetzt gerade noch Buchstaben
also ein Happy Birthday Malik und ich
werde jetzt hier die Torte schon mal
weiter glatt streichen denn dann kann
sie eigentlich gleich aufgestellt werden
und wir können alles draufsetzen
[Musik]
was ist eigentlich dein Lieblingskuchen
ich liebe Zwetschgenkuchen
aus
gefällt mir so würde ich also lassen
denn ich finde es muss gar nicht super
perfekt glatt sein
und die Torte kommt noch mal ganz kurz
in den Kühlschrank und dann stelle ich
sie direkt schon auf eine Servierplatte
damit der Teddybär hier schön fertig
dekoriert werden kann als ihr seht
richtig einfach und ganz schnell
es wird jetzt ein bisschen komisch
denn man muss sie aufstellen
perfekt und jetzt einfach noch die
Rückseite bestreichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich muss sagen die Torte ist ein sehr
gut gelungen absolut hat auch richtig
Spaß gemacht mit dir auch wenn ich die
Hälfte der Zeit alleine war und du dazu
gekommen bist aber das nächste Mal
backen wir einfach von Anfang an
zusammen
[Gelächter]
ich will einfach viel mehr Zeit mit dir
verbringen
ich bin echt sauer auf meine Schwester
weil sie weggezogen
15 15 schon aber vor 14 habt ihr
geheiratet ja 15 Manu also falls ihr
noch mehr Videos von uns beiden sehen
wollt dann schreibt es gerne in die
Kommentare oder ja absolut und wenn
nicht packe ich einfach meinen
Kamerateam oder nach Aachen und dann
zeigst du uns dort deine Welt ja mache
ich auch gerne klar
was finden wie findest du die Torte komm
hier ich habe die mit Eiche Käse
gebacken
oder warte
und
süß gehen wir morgen auf den Geburtstag
von Malik weißt du was wir jetzt machen
können
wir können jetzt happy Birthday singen
und wenn der Malik irgendwann groß genug
ist dass er sich unsere Videos anschaut
dann sieht er dass wir ihm diese Torte
heute gebacken haben und das wäre für
ihn gesungen haben sollen wir machen
okay
und ich verabschiede mich jetzt schon
mal das Rezept findet ihr in meiner App
und falls ihr weitere Tier Torten sehen
wollt oder Motiv Wünsche habt dann
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare denn
ich finde das ist eine richtig tolle
einfache Geburtstagstorte die jeder
nachmachen kann eins
und eins zwei drei vier sieben birthday
to you
happy birthday to you
happy Birthday lieber lieber
[Musik]